is tracking Taylor Swift against the law
well after Jack Sweeney published the
location of Swift's private jet her
lawyer sent him a cease and assist
letter Sweeney runs a database where he
compiles private jet information of
Swift Mark Cuban Elon Musk and others
when musk offered him $5,000 to stop
tracking his plane swey CED with $50,000
and musk didn't respond and instead just
shut down the account but it's not
censorship as Swift's lawyers say that
if Sweeney doesn't stop this Behavior
she will have no choice but to pursue
any and all legal remedies but remember
anyone can send a cease and toist letter
for anything and here's the tell the
letter does doesn't mention a specific
crime so does Swift have a legal case
well jet tracking is not illegal in the
United States all aircraft registration
is public information as possible the
only person in America who's protected
from jet tracking is Florida Governor
Ronda Sanz who signed a law that permits
him to conceal details of his private
and public flights after Sweeny had been
tracking him just lawyers say that she
lives in fear for her life because of
stalkers and that might be true but it
also might not be legally fixable but if
you need a great lawyer for things that
are legally flexible then let my firm
the eagle team take care of it the link
is below